nous sommes dans l'édifice où se trouve
le bureau de premier ministre à québec
ici les caméras ont généralement
mais à situation exceptionnelle
permission exceptionnelle
ce matin le gouvernement est dans les
derniers préparatifs en vue de l'arrivée
des migrants seriez au québec alors ce
matin on est on est en phase pré
opérationnelle autour de la table huit
ministres les directeurs de cabinet du
ministre williams est le plus haut
fonctionnaire de l'état québécois
le blues est aussi personnel c'est une
contracture manque de temps et 13
c'est comme un putting et biologiques
dans quelques jours les premiers dès
1800 migrants seriez parrainé par l'état
atterriront à montréal les temps presse
on a perdu alors une offre de 10 maximum
la réunion se tiendra sans nous en
raison de son caractère confidentiel
moi je vais renconter oui entre une
rencontre et un rendez vous les
ministres de la sécurité publique nous
donne venus même un aperçu
le rôle du ministre c'est pas de dire ça
prend six chaises ça prend un air de
repos faut prévoir des chambres d'hôtel
le rôle du ministre c'est dire comment
tu es ce que ces gens là seront
accueillis expliqué le mois et c'est
pour ça que la qualité des équipes avec
laquelle on travaille est aussi
important nous allons retrouver le
coordonnateur gouvernemental à
l'organisation de la sécurité civile
un étage du ton du rock ici on est au
centre d'opérations du gouvernement du
québec
donc c'est d'ici que on est ouvert 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
en tout 30 ministères sont mises à
contribution pour ce qu on a baptisé le
rs l'opération réfugiés syriens et on a
mobilisé l'organisation sécurité civile
officiellement le 19 mai on note que
j'arrivais justement d'être dans
l'action à ceux de ce côté là il était
le plat de tester le plein mais de
l'adapter aussi les réfugiés à yves par
la navette ici un autobus à la fois
l'opération commence samedi
mais déjà à tout est pratiquement fin
prêt les forces canadiennes la croix
rouge toutes les équipes sont mobilisées
moi ma fébrilité c'est dire j'espère que
ce sera un succès tout le monde veut
faire de cette opération un succès ne
manque plus que ceux pour qui toute
cette opération est mise en oeuvre ici
julie dufresne radio canada québec